Zach wrote this role with you in mind
and you even previously mentioned that
he put elements of you into the script
was it intimidating to tackle such a
complex role knowing it was kind of made
with you in mind
um it would seem like it should be but
it really wasn't
um I think what happens when someone who
knows you so well and knows your body of
work so well writes you something is you
kind of cut about Seven Corners we don't
have to create that dialogue between
each other I don't have to spend ages
figuring out who Alison is I was there
from the beginning I was a part of the
conversation of who she is and and and
and and where she comes to from the very
very beginning
um and it just meant that as a performer
all I really needed to to do was then
come and breathe life into her and and
figure out how I wanted her to be
um it's it was very freeing actually
having so much of the work already done
because we'd already discussed so much
of it you know
yeah and I was gonna say you have an
incredible singing voice and I know you
wrote A lot of the songs was that part
of the process when you were
understanding the character of Alice
totally I mean Zach uh corrected me
yesterday that he he had always intended
for some song some piano to be in there
because that's what was uh based on the
character but for me when I wrote uh one
of the songs I hate myself I it was I
was truly really trying to get in the
headspace of her I was trying to figure
out at what low she must be in like how
does she think of herself where does she
want to be what does she think about
doing to herself and it was kind of just
like a stab of figuring out who this
woman was and where we were going to go
from there and then when I played the
song for Zach I was like is this kind of
what you're thinking is this is this
where she is and he was like yeah that's
exactly it so that's the song that's in
the in the in the movie
and then on top of that you know you
have to think about how does she sound
how does she sound and and how broken is
she and
um you know I think there's there's
always a bit of a fear when you when you
pre-record things that it's then gonna
suddenly be really glossy and glittery
and in this storyline it doesn't make
sense so we kind of made the decision to
keep it as raw and as as as honest as
possible on a creaky piano in the rehab
center with a creaky voice and and just
that's probably how broken and low she
is so it was really cool to do both yeah
yeah and in this film you get to share
so many scenes with the legendary Morgan
Freeman how is it working alongside such
an iconic actor such as him oh it's so
easy you know when you're working with
someone that is that uh professional
that talented
um he he knew every single cue every
single line he was on it he was on on
set
you know it's it's like playing acting
tennis with someone
um just anything I serve he hits back
and you end up feeling very secure in
the scene when you're working with
someone like that and there really truly
is just this magic that only you two are
living in in that moment and the cat the
camera is capturing and um yeah it's
just it's like playing you know you're
just you're playing with this Legend who
is is so unbelievably talented that we
know so well
um and it's uh it's it's a joy truly to
say that to have said that I I worked
with Morgan well I would say you're a
young Legend yourself and it was great
to see you to share the screen thank you
so much for your time thank you so much
thanks for chatting you wrote this uh
role specifically with Florence in mind
what was it about her that you knew she
would be perfect for this role I just
think she's just like everybody else on
Earth I just think she's the most
incredible actress you know I mean and
all these filmmakers the legendary
a-listers are agree you know Christopher
Nolan and
and Ari Astor and Greta Gerwig
everyone's lining up to to work with her
she's she's just a one-of-a-kind
um once in a generation level talent and
I just I I wanted to write something for
her and I just felt so lucky that she
she liked what I wrote
yeah and I know you said that you wrote
this movie while you were dealing with a
lot of grief was this a cathartic
experience to see the finished product
and did it help you process your grief
throughout the film The thing I'm
feeling most Joy about is when I when
I'm now sharing it with audiences I've
been touring around the country and
doing Q and A's and and when you see the
audience response to it in a theater
that's that's the thing that feels great
because these feelings are often you
know of grief and loss are often very
lonely times in in one's life and to
have the communal experience of sharing
it with others and then seeing them
empathize and relate and see it and see
see the story in their own lives that's
when it feels so wonderful because it's
you know I needed to be reminded that
these are very human Universal feelings
that we we all go through
yeah I was gonna say in the film there's
so many Beautiful Moments of laughter
and joy amongst all this chaos and you
really blend it beautifully together but
you also have the help of this
incredible cast what's it like knowing
that you can call up the likes of Morgan
Freeman as well as Molly two people
you've worked with in the past and just
say hey I have a new film do you want to
be in it well I never knew I didn't know
that either one of them said yes you
know I I directed Morgan in a big Studio
comedy and Morgan doesn't do a whole lot
of independent movies I I didn't really
know that you know we shot this movie in
26 days that's not a normal schedule for
someone like Morgan you know we needed
to really go fast we needed to shoot a
lot of pages every day it's a very
intense role I just didn't know if you
wanted to go there anymore uh you know I
was gonna call upon him to go really dig
deep and and go to a dark place
and Morgan just he loved the script and
he said yes and um and Molly you're
right my very first episode of Scrubs I
ever directed Molly happened to be the
guest star and I knew her as just a
brilliant comedienne but I I also from
that episode saw that she had a
wonderful dramatic uh acting ability
so um she was you know I knew that she
could do it I needed someone who could
be funny but also a wonderful actress
yeah and I think that you directed them
perfectly in this film I'm curious to
know what is your biggest hope and
takeaway that you hope audiences take
from watching a good person well I hope
that audiences go to the theater because
people are always saying they don't make
movies for adults anymore they make you
know the only thing that comes out is
Big action movies I really hope that
people go see this because I I I I I
attempted to do that make something that
that will that will inspire conversation
and and self-reflection and you know
it's the kind of movie you that leaves a
lot up for interpretation and discussion
so I hope that people go and and and
have a chance to chat with their friends
about it
thank you so much uh it was incredible
film it took me on a roller coaster of
emotions and I can't wait for other
people to see it thank you man I really
appreciate it this film deals with some
heavy subject matter and yet there are
so many moments of laughter and joy
especially from the character as an
actor how did you find the balance of
the two especially in a film with such
dark moments well I think Zach Braff our
director is so good at that he really
knows how to when it's like too dark and
when to kind of lighten it up with a
funny scene about Shark Tank or whatever
so really I credit Zach Braff without
our amazing director writer and
um Florence is such an amazing dramatic
actress but she's also so funny so she
brings humor to her part too and same
with Morgan Freeman he has just like a
wink in his eye he can do this brilliant
dramatic work but then he's got humor so
I think it's just all the performers
together
um but it was Zach just struck a great
balance between comedy and drama I think
yeah and Zach's so well known for his
Incredible Gift of Storytelling what was
it about Zach that you loved working
with him the most from his writing to
his directing to all of it well he's so
great because I mean I worked with him
20 years ago on Scrubs he directed an
episode that I did and people it was
like a an episode that a lot of people
would oh I loved you on Scrubs it was
very dramatic and so Zach believed that
I could do this dramatic part but also
be funny
um so he he's such a good director
because he's an actor so he knows how to
talk to actors because he's an actor
himself so he just has like a shorthand
because he gets it and not not all
directors are like that so he'll be like
that was great Molly okay try it like
this he just works fast and it just
feels really easy there's like he's just
happy on set and you know funny and it's
just it's just like fun and Florence and
I it's funny when we were playing mother
and daughter I had never met her before
but we just clicked right away and she's
just so funny in real life and so we did
have a real instant connection right
away talking and
um so that was so fun too and she's just
such a she's just like one of our
greatest young actresses and she's like
a powerhouse on set she just commands a
set like no one else and she loves to
cook after she's shoots and she's just
so fun to have dinner with and she's
just a wonderful girl yeah I was gonna
say the two of you had some such amazing
chemistry you could when you're you are
events going together my eyes were glued
to the screens but I do hear Whispers
that behind the scenes Florence would
cook for everyone now and again to
de-stress was there a meal that she
cooked for you was there something that
you really love from behind the scenes
on the set no I haven't gotten to eat to
eat anything she cooked but we did go
out for dinners like at restaurants but
um she was trying to get me at Christmas
because we were shooting in November I
was like I think I'm gonna make a turkey
and she was like no Molly don't make a
turkey you've got to make a Christmas
goose which was so very English of her
to suggest but she told I I didn't do it
but she but I she told me how to do it
so if I decide to do it in the future
she was like you've gotta put it in
water then you hang it to dry overnight
to let it dry out and she told me how to
make it really crispy and it sounds so
good she made it sound very good so I
have a fantasy to soon someday make a
Florence Pew Christmas goose or just not
Christmas just a Florence Pew Goose
crispy goose